hi my name is Brian Cranston and I feel
stimulated to being on to being to about
being
I just can't say it I think you just
couldn't get Beyond stimulus yeah once I
said that once you said stimulated uh
the whole atmosphere in the room changed
yeah still stemi it's a steamy yeah
steamy stimulation for Brian Cranston
O'Brien's friend yeah I think that's
what Conan O'Brien's friend that's where
I stumbled
oh cruel no yeah cruel and unnecessary a
man of your stature no because I haven't
entered into the pantheon of that my
great friends brother and yes like Sona
and Matt yes what does that mean
look it's the world's oldest profession
oh so I'm told yes we never had any
experience you didn't I did you did yeah
let's get into it Brian Cranston you
were with a uh
Lady of the evening ones huh yes I was a
virgin and I was traveling with a bunch
of friends in Europe I was 16 years old
and uh it was the thing to do and I I
was actually looking forward to it and
nervous as hell of course I'm 16. yeah
and a bunch of friends who we were out
together and it's like we're going to do
this let's go let's go go yeah yeah sure
let's go oh God and we go to this uh the
red light district in Salzburg Austria
whoa okay and my two older friends they
were about a year and a half older than
me and they're going in and I and I
start to get cold feet and and I said I
I don't think I brought enough money I
don't think I and I have enough uh
Austrian Franks to be able to
make this transaction huh sure
and uh and they they both made their
deals and they went upstairs and I said
no I I I don't have the money or trying
to indicate in the universal language
right don't have it or whatever and I
sat down in the foyer and then this
woman came up to me and everyone's older
than you when you're 16. yes I could not
tell you how old she was
she came up and she goes indicated my
pockets I go oh no no see and she said
no no see I'll show you that I don't
have enough see that's just not I like
this is nothing this is not and she
grabbed the money and to grab my hands
and ah like oh my Lord and I went oh my
God oh my God oh my God this is
happening this is happening oh my God oh
my God oh my God we go into this room
there's a single bed there's a sink and
a trash can that's it oh Jesus so I had
to see just goes you know she points to
my clothes like yeah you know like this
she's preparing her sand she really sets
the move oh my God
yeah my penis would be up inside my body
at this point it would have retracted
into my left lung
we have its little arms crossed
oh you are a woman you're a woman
no I swear I swear uh yeah so then I had
to stand up while taking my clothes off
and I put it on a hook and she goes huh
come on you know and and uh
I knew I I it was like oh my God I was
so nervous that I didn't really feel
anything I was just my brain was on fire
and at one point I thought oh I should I
should touch your breasts
clip the red wire not the blue one and
it was it was like which one should I
touch I don't I I don't know and so I
just touched one of her breasts and all
of a sudden I just felt her hand slap
mine
sorry sorry I'm sorry just she slapped
my hand oh my God to take my hand off
her breasts uh so uh yeah because that
was out of bounds you didn't pay enough
yeah
that's true exactly right that's
probably it like no no no you get this
McDonald's meal yes but you don't get
the extra large fries and you don't get
the shake yeah and there's no prize yeah
none so uh the deed was done yeah yeah
wow 16. yeah and then and then of course
out I go and my friends were coming down
the stairs and of course I was smoking
my imaginary cigarette
how was yours
but I say that it's like it's it was a
traumatic and a great exhilarating uh
memorable experience man it was it was a
seminal moment in a in a person's life
when they lose their virginity yeah yeah
I've been going back to Austria ever
since I know
Brian I'm looking here it says that
you've shot your last seven movies in
in the whole Conan it really and the
exchange rate is really good very
talented Cruise yeah you're often seen
with a now 110 year old woman listen
walking hand in hand in the marketplace
please don't address Heidi that way she
is very sensitive
[Laughter]
I've seen her wow uh wow wow you know
what I loved about that we were just
starting to chat yeah and I didn't I
didn't get us there there was some joke
and then we called prostate yeah yeah
yeah which is a really funny joke and
then uh Brian's just like well if you're
going to drag it out of me
I was one of the Watergate
co-conspirators
laughs